so I did want to there was a situation
that happened yeah I would like to know
about this and it's a truth it's a it's
a true situation okay but not everybody
knows who had happened - I know who had
happened you do and I would not hide
right we could just tell you in
bah-bah-bah or I want to know it could
we could we could play a game okay Rob
Anthony and neek okay the whole [ __ ]
crew is here whose dick is going in my
mouth hold on Jim Marrs pointing to
himself I'm uh
you cannot just jump on on this bad boy
over here Oh what which one is that six
or eight eight it should be your cap
microphone no I cannot hear you and
there's all the way up no that's not
much it's weird what like is that
because what's one two three four is
there one for six um no I do not see
sell your head okay try that try that so
um yeah so I thought there was an old
game and it's a old game show and it's
it's shown in in that movie catch me if
you can't you ever seen a movie my
classic love that movie guy who makes a
takes the wrong point the part where
Christopher so the movie opens with
Frank Abagnale on a game show called to
tell true story by the way gorgeous
about the movie but it's called to tell
the truth and tell the truth is an old
game show sure that works where three
people line up and they're all telling
the same story okay and only one of them
is telling the truth that's true and so
it's gonna be up to you and Jim Norton
to figure out which one of our three
beautiful men are telling the truth okay
okay who thick am i punching you don't
have to punch any difficulty no no you
can actually would just take turns
there's no buzzer so you don't have to
punch it okay right so Rob will stand
over there do we have any any any music
there it is no I get fit to tell the
truth music
[Music]
welcome to tell the truth yes there it
is welcome everybody you don't stand
next to the contestants Rob what are you
doing you're putzing around what do you
need a headphones for you can hear me
exactly Rob damn it's a piece of good
luck you just because you're more
handsome than the rest you're not
special Mike really has been easy for
him it really has we have our
contestants here Anthony
step up there's Anthony how's everybody
doing Nico going and Rob hello and by
the way Anthony why are you wearing
headphones I because I'm just I'm gonna
pass them off to whoever goes up here
okay Jim marry all three of these
gentlemen are in their early to mid for
fur Anthony may be pushing towards late
20s yeah but they're all all men in
their 20s
yep with our whole lives ahead of them
Jim Mary one of these men was on a bus
48 hours ago okay one of these men had
stomach problems on the bus 48 hours ago
and thought they'd let out some and
thought they'd let out some gas yes Jim
Mary
one of these men took a giant deuce irui
in their pants on the best Jim Mary I'd
like for you guys to find out which of
these three men are here to tell the
truth
oh [ __ ] that's right yes so if you guys
want to take turn Jim you just has one
simple question of one contestant okay
and then did you [ __ ] your pants they're
all they're all gonna say yes two are
lying one is telling the truth okay okay
so you asked one contestant a question
then it's Mary's turn to ask can one
contestant okay another question until
one of you goes whose ass am i smelling
I know who it is
you wouldn't smell it and would just be
questions it's a network show here's my
question here's my question
yeah can I say that where is the bus
headed okay and which contestant are you
asking all you ask one at a time
Iko Nika where was the boss you don't
need headphones where where was the bus
headed Nico approach the microphone and
let Judy go he goes hands behind his
back she's panicking New Jersey Joe says
the answer is New Jersey okay Mary do
you have a question for any of the three
contestants and may we figure out who is
tell you don't ask all three there's
nothing okay no you don't Mary do you
have a which contestant would you like
to ask a question to did you go again
okay Nico back to the microphone what's
your question Mary oh the smell
did it smell a little bit a little bit
okay all right he says a little bit is
Nico telling the truth we don't know Rob
what did you have for lunch that day
McDonald's oh that's an answer that
would make sense Jimmy's right but is it
true we don't know Mary
Anthony mm-hmm yes did he take a dump
before leaving your house that morning
no that would make sense that is you
know Jim Anthony who are you sitting
next to on the bus
an old woman an old woman okay I already
see I can see in Jim's head he's
starting to develop some theories based
on context and body language is that
right yes that's what I thought Mary Rob
another question for ya
how long did it take you to go home that
day it usually it's an hour and 10
minutes
we were truck stuck in traffic a little
bit so okay okay okay okay okay I've got
I've got my yeah okay all right I know
the answer you already know the answer
now Nico um what did you do the minute
you got off the bus walk to my car okay
watch his car I guess his car must have
been parked at the bus stop okay okay
he's not a good question and whenever
whenever either of you it thinks they're
ready for a guess you can go ahead and
say I'm gonna guess but you get one
guess okay and you don't want to lose
this game Wow shoes there's a lot on the
line you can keep asking questions okay
okay so Mary go back to asking questions
Rob yeah yes did you have sex that day
no that was a waste of a question
Sara Lee but that's a very Mary Jean
question I'm sorry Niko Niko when you
got home
how long after did you take a shower
about five minutes must have been a long
five minutes if he's telling the truth
he could be lying because that's what
we're here to find out we're here to see
who is here to tell the truth
Mary what's your next question Rob have
you ever douche before have I ever
deduced before Mary your [ __ ] to get
[ __ ] I've been robbed have you ever
douched before no but now I'm gonna look
it up okay okay could be fun
could be fun again odd question but
still fits it fits
mmm cuz maybe he would have had to
douche but he said he doesn't this [ __ ]
got stuck but he said he's never douched
so Anthony you questioning did you
change your pants when you got home
yes okay all right there's the yes
married you have another question I
think I know who shouldn't you're ready
to guess yeah okay Mary who is here to
tell the truth I detest by the way the
hot dog no just joking he's looking for
attention he's actually in the other
room [ __ ] his pants right back yes
yeah no he actually reached back and
pulled a new iPhone out all right Mary
you have a guess you want to guess now
yeah you want to you want to I want the
money okay the [ __ ] I'm gonna go with
Rob you think Rob is here to tell the
truth Rob did you come into the studio
today to tell the truth Sam yeah no I
did not oh my goodness it didn't happen
to Rob Jim would you like to make a
guess of the final two or would you like
an extra question maybe one extra
question sir what cuz I was thinking Rob
at one point yeah that's amazing
I was thinking Mary you have
unfortunately you have lost the game you
will not go home with the money or the
[ __ ]
you'll get no [ __ ] Sam [ __ ] home in a
jar no I'll still mail that to you yeah
yeah it's a don't poop again
what have we covered already we've
already covered their bus yeah
but Baba who who would be an adult man
who would take a big [ __ ] in his pants
happen to anyone in public but that
could happen to any buddy
Saul Frisco that made Anthony [ __ ] where
do you live well I'll tell you this I'll
tell you this it would have been the
same day as the del first go state is 48
hours ago yeah I would have been the
same Anthony where do you live I live in
Jersey and Nico too huh Nico also lives
in Jersey okay guys the one that takes
the train home yeah
against my better judgment I am gonna
say Nico against against his better
judgment he guesses Nico even though
it's a risk I hate to say here in
Assumption Nico Jim wants to know did
you enter the studio today he said tell
the truth yeah
Anthony [ __ ] would have been too
good to be true and on his day and Niko
said something I think he said yes or
five but there was one answer you gave
that I'm like I believe it yeah there
was a I thought that uh and again I knew
so I was watching with a discerning eye
Robb [ __ ] up when he talked about how
long it takes to get home because first
he goes well usually it takes it took an
hour in ten minutes
that was true well when he said usually
that didn't [ __ ] me up because I thought
maybe he jumped off the and got and went
into a place to wash his s I thought
maybe he got off the bus and took longer
and then Anthony his only real [ __ ]
was he went into acting mode when when
well yes when you asked him who was
sitting next to him he went that was a
good answer what Anthony lost me was
when there was something happened he
looked down with y'all shucks it was me
when he did that that was when I was
like nah I think he's bullshitting good
Anthony always wanted to be a child
actor now even more so after his corey
feldman talking but then nico I just
kind of I was like yeah that's a dude
who shits his pants to happen you go
would you like what happened we'd like
to come up to the microphone and let's
get into your story now when I soso
words good good news spreads quickly
it's coming up yesterday I was coming up
the the elevator and I was lucky enough
to share an elevator with handsome
handsome Robbie lucky is the operative
word and he goes oh just get a good text
it was like what now it was that an
upsetting text when you got it hold on
okay I was so happy yeah in the morning
walking to work when Anthony to have the
text yeah we were in the elevator
it's the first thing you said to me
Anthony texted him immediately because I
guess Nico early in the first thing in
the morning told Anthony kind of
bashfully right did you know that this
would go out over the air were you
trying to yeah oh my god who texted you
oh Anthony texted you what did it say
Roboto
dear Rob Nico should his pants on the
bus that's it baby
like he [ __ ] his pants in the in the
morning right yeah I wish it was that
what did you write back no ducking way
so uh Nico what happened I was waiting
for the bus and I got something to eat
and then what do you eat yeah
chick-fil-a okay that lousy would you
get the chick-fil-a Nuggets okay this
just awful
no there's awful you're out of your mind
I didn't like it I didn't like it it was
okay you know where those nuggets ended
up
I do yeah and the [ __ ] liquid form
all over that bus seat yeah all over the
local it is only all all under root
Nuggets is what they were so what
happened you bought Nuggets so I was
waiting for the bus and I just started
eating I was eating slow and then about
ten minutes before the bus came my
stomach started hurting do you get the
gurgles and what did your head earlier
because that's too soon for that to
bother you yeah what did you had earlier
I had like a rap from Dunkin Donuts okay
what's in the rap getting him you might
have been one of that it's Dunkin Donuts
I yeah Dunkin Donuts back home okay all
right I had like before I got on the bus
in the morning yeah Negin ham see you
stomach was a little Christian have
something to eat sure maybe dinner
before wasn't the greatest it might have
been yeah you eat the Nuggets and your
stomach's hurting
it was just hurting like yes cuz I'm not
used to it I've never had them sometimes
like sometimes there's a little fire in
your belly right and you fast food and
you've literally thrown grease on the
phone that's not good then I was just
waiting so it's like it started hurting
I was like you know what if I go to the
bathroom or if I least try I'm gonna
miss the bus was like no I'll just hold
it I like that like a little kid he's
like I might try to did you try to make
you did you poop we know I didn't have
to did you try
I told you to tread least try before you
get on the bus I try to go so I don't
have to go at that point so it's like
I'll hold it and then out of all days
that day the bus decided to go to the
towns where we don't normally ot always
a lot more stops yeah so people decided
to go to the towns that we don't stop at
so we had to go through East orange and
orange and there's just like how much
extra time did that add 15 oh so you
might have made it so I was like I
couldn't make I would make it so Roger
borrow that detail from the story
whether longer bus
so you're on your way home when did you
realize there was a problem my stomach
just like oh he was the pain I've never
felt the pain filming you start to cramp
up really a bit like worse than ever
almost you wonder his pains yeah like I
was wishing it was at least gasp did you
wonder if maybe you were finally getting
your first period I see you stomach is
hurting so where were you when you first
started taking the bus all the way to
Jersey if I had like some kind of
crystal ball that told me today is the
day that Nico's gonna [ __ ] his pants a
big time on the bus I would have taken a
knee codepen like saying what you doing
on the bus don't worry about it I can
see someone nowhere yeah I'm taking I
don't know what's your stop but you're
still on them buddy I don't worry about
it bro just imagine his his face when he
starts [ __ ] his family oh did it smell
he knows what's happening nobody know I
were you how far from home were you and
your like I started it was the parkway I
was able to control it then so it was
like controllable this is what I can get
home all I visualize you know I have an
8 month old and he makes this like when
he shits his pants his face gets red and
he starts going like this I picture is
Nico starting be really going alright
she's feeling it happening on the park
well you still have to get home so then
we get down like orange and I'm just
like it's nice it's not gonna hold
orange is about to turn brown what we
party complete party wish I was able to
are you trying to fart
I wouldn't even it wasn't even fired you
knew his [ __ ] when he goes and it just
came out and he looks to the heavens
this is to say why
was it a liquidy one no it was a solid
one it was pretty solid shittier pants
it was it wasn't like diarrhea no that's
excusable you took a real a solid man
it wasn't like little pebbles no it was
a full [ __ ] how much came out how much
that's [ __ ] cool that's a lot of [ __ ]
picture that much put it like plutonium
a lot a [ __ ] log came out it relieved
the pain just for like about until I can
get home so I was able like see you get
in your car this [ __ ] go what kind of
Underpants do you wear boxer briefs is
just box just boxer is there but you
don't wear like I mean they're not crazy
but they're like a you know a baggy
fitting machine like aren't you worried
at all that like you're wearing boxers
and jeans that it's gonna fall down the
line did it fall down the leg on the
walk home you [ __ ] did I did that
when I was in fifth grade you [ __ ]
had a piece of [ __ ] fall from your
underpants down your leg can you imagine
feeling that like roll down the back of
your thigh yeah I can oh yeah I hope
what where'd it get stuck
he's pointing down below the knee on the
left side right to the leg where your
sock starts no didn't get down to the
side was it leaving a trail like a
little [ __ ] a little look at you when
you got off the bus no but the guy in
front of me I guess he might smell
because he was looking around what'd it
smell like a baby donkey I think I know
that smell
I think the young man back there might
have made poop in his pants that's what
they would say when they did are the kid
[ __ ] his pants it happens what are you
gonna do
I've never shipped myself on a bus I
don't think in my adult life I've ever
shipped myself have I ended up I don't
know I'm
a little sneak out like a chef sharted
you have so it's not like a full solid
log now they're gonna that was it gonna
dump man [ __ ] your pants so the walk
home like explain this to me you get to
your car how to walk to my car and then
once I got to my car just raced home but
when did so when does this [ __ ] start
rolling down your leg when I was walking
like an egg off the bus I started
walking and then I suppose walking to
this to my car it rolls just started
little by little just dropping Nikko did
he say bye to your [ __ ] after you saw it
go down like [ __ ] you got in your car in
your car you're sitting I feel like I
would shake shake it out my leg I was
thinking about it when I was like am I
gonna parked in a pizzeria and I was
like I can't really I'd rather have the
[ __ ] in the pizzeria than in my car no
you thinking about going into a store I
was like it's too risky did you have to
stiff leg like when you sat in the car
did you have to sit with like your torso
stiff so your ass didn't touch the seat
you didn't just sit with your [ __ ] nice
to be here but I just said I was more
worried about coming out of well you
actually sat with a [ __ ] half a log
still poked me out with their excrement
between your cheeks how long drive home
was it but you didn't you didn't even
like you know you take your left leg and
you [ __ ] stiffen up I've almost [ __ ]
my pants in LA I had to skip it up so I
keep my like your asses off the seat
yeah because that pressure makes you go
more you don't know that you just sat
you just sat down
ringworm now those clothes
you didn't throw them out memories just
watch them you put them in the wine but
aren't you worried that [ __ ] will get in
your washing machine
shake out everywhere that day it did
when I was a kid I would [ __ ] my pants
so often then I remember my mother
stopped cleaning them and I used to have
to take
I remember the process of scrubbing out
my [ __ ] underwear I would have to take
soap and water and warm in the sink and
then the the way you take for the fabric
in the hands and you scrub it together
on itself to clean it [ __ ] your pants
all the time it's good yeah yeah why
would anybody think you were ever
molested but I did a lot so I understand
that but to me this sitting it is crazy
so where did you don't think I mean
look it happens to the best of us yeah
it does right what'd you do with the
what'd you do with the Nugget how did
you get it out of your leg and it fell
out nicely so you never lost it on your
way home it was like when you have a box
of cereal and you get a toy in there and
stuck on you're like why won't this
[ __ ] toy come out of the body cept
it's poo poo that's humiliating it is so
space you know what is funnier huh then
an adult [ __ ] their pants you know I
have to tell you Jim I've known a lot of
comedians I can't think of not one thing
I can't think of anything that would
make a bunch of guys happier than
hearing someone they know [ __ ] is pay
yeah if you understand why I had so much
pomp and circumstance around this story
like like this is wonderful
yeah it's a wonderful news so you
reached into your pants with your hands
no I just took took it I just got my
pants and I took it inside out oh yeah
maybe you just kind of shook it over the
toilet [ __ ] where are you yeah and then
so like and then and then you you take
your boxers down and I'm sure there's
[ __ ] all over and that was a total mess
cuz it was soft like you said he was on
you have a soft stool so there was a
soft but solid one yeah yeah
so you weren't food poisoned by the way
he was I think it was just because I'm
not used to eating just coming who's
just fell and [ __ ] his pants ain't
control his bowels he's just made his
pants yeah I just made in his pants
he made cocky in his pants yeah he ate
too much his little tummy was fault yeah
that's all because that was not like
there wasn't diarrhea wasn't diarrhea
wasn't a stomach issue yeah you didn't
have a diary or a problem no you know
you ate too much and your little tummy
hurt yeah and you made it you made me
pee that he made him took a poo poo
didn't anything so and then after you
take your your boxers off and you're
like that's a total mess do you
immediately get in the shower and just
scrub away I did
where's that brown water disgusting
isn't it yeah and then after two
did you try to get the rest out before
the shower or after the shower before
okay so you say I can clean all at once
you shake your pants out and then you
sit on the toilet to try to get the rest
out of your bottom good okay and then
you have to scrub everything because
then there's there's Dookie on your leg
and did you [ __ ] a lot after this your
toilet after that we flush yeah you're
gonna make you're gonna get Dookie skids
on the toilets are you ever amazed where
you see [ __ ] spatter I see sometimes
like on the underside of this stuff like
I haven't [ __ ] wild look what's
happening yeah really no I usually know
when I do that's like every morning for
me but like when I'm not [ __ ] wild
I'm like how the [ __ ] is this getting
all over the place well I mean try you
taking you take defecating like it's a
sport you take performance-enhancing
drug I mean there's mornings after my
coffee it looks like Kennedy's motorcade
on the toilet all liquidy yeah it's
literally like an orgasm of [ __ ] LBJ
comes in kicks Troy took a mound of [ __ ]
that's out oh wow okay look I'm not on
the bus
no although honestly two weeks ago I
urinated all over myself why I was
driving home I was stuck in traffic was
your head being held by a young lady I
was in traffic heading back to the city
and I had a piece so bad and so I had a
little cup and I was peeing in it but I
had it tilted so I was peeing in it and
then the XSP was coming out and dripping
all over inside my pants on the car seat
when you got a stop dude I used to pull
over and have to do it and you stop and
pull over you whiz then you take it to a
napkin you cover your [ __ ] so the
drops can come out dump it out the
window put the cup back I used to do
that for hours well be riding around
looking at girls all night stop 2003
2004 when I was depressed Yeah right
you're gonna stop me over the back ride
some hookers don't touch that cup you
ever we talked to Niko's dad came with
him to the internship that's right did
ya your parents are very involved in
your life you're only 20 years old yeah
they're very your parents are very very
you're still the little baby
there little boy you're only 20 so did
you did you have to tell mommy and daddy
that you you made a little Niko in your
pan told them to have the doors open
you told them what just to have the door
unlocks so I have to unlock oh you call
before you know I was just like have the
door open
you told your parents you shoot your
parents Oh after I took the shower so
yeah it looks oh my god I made my pants
you go have the door open just have it
unlock so I don't have to stand there
and I'll walk and they said okay yeah
and so a but they didn't ask questions
you're just like are you home he wanted
mommy and daddy another name and he made
so you ran in the house with the door
open you cleaned yourself up and then
did you bring your poo poo pants to your
mom and say can you wash these I made
myself myself you did yeah you know boy
when you said when you told you you had
an accident wash my clothes how did you
tell you had an accident he's a man I
like that how did you tell her I [ __ ] my
pants you just said that you know what
it is what happened I got my pan how'd
she respond oh this will honey me first
you learn how to use the laundry machine
then you learn how to use the toilet she
walked away mama [ __ ] my pants she looks
like don't need anything else she just
walked away yeah she walked away I said
don't eat anything shouldn't have any
follow-up questions and she didn't want
to know she's just like what did I raise
yeah farm animals Oneko it happens Nico
you sure your dad he was just like you
can go stay outside the dogs know they
made funny yeah 20 years old yeah I
think I never take shits you don't right
now you're a lady yeah you no never
you might fire big logs never gem I've
never taken a [ __ ] in my whole life
ladies don't do that no I know their
body recycles the food and they use it
for energy exactly
I understand incoming yeah Nico :
no energy needed just leave it on the
bus yeah I mean plate as it lies let me
go sir absolutely that's me goes I bet
you when he had this [ __ ] he probably
just kept looking at the Twitter feed he
was or whoever he's looking at a reading
and just lifted his cheek and shat and
just kept going
I suspect you were more comfortable with
this than you're letting on what was
going on in your head we did you know
were you thinking like oh ouch my belly
you like praying oh my god I'm gonna
[ __ ] I think I'm gonna [ __ ] you could
feel you were gonna show us like the
worst pain I've ever had I've ever had
that pain I know I've been able to hold
it at least the day you're asking the
Lord to help you you were praying to God
that you don't [ __ ] your pants and God
instead of answering your prayers
hm I prayed it wasn't a good weakness no
that's a great week we're talking about
well yet no fun game out of it
right well I'll tell you this there was
rumor around that Nikko stock was gonna
be lessened tremendously because if you
remember on Monday on my on Monday Mikko
metaphorically [ __ ] the bed and in order
to recover from that he had to literally
[ __ ] himself
you should the bed to metaphoric Oh
remember I remember on Monday he came in
and he accused me of stealing my own
camera and then said Troy me were
probably gay - yeah yeah it's just a
weird exactly was half right we're weird
more s not that funny Rob just a weird
morning Rob knows victory punch him in
the dick for me Mary but that was a
weird morning but I feel like somehow
you I feel like you've recovered
what do you what do you guys think he
goes back you think he's back yes yeah
this is a good day for him yeah Anthony
as a guy who knows a thing or two about
stock going up and down you know you
barely know cut down that's true I don't
know it's like you're on the upswing
though now after ya know what do you
think happened Anthony the the intern
you know that [ __ ] his pants on the bus
is being condescending I didn't want to
jinx him but I guess you know now you
might as well bring up well you think
okay how is today for you honestly it
was it was alright pretty good right
there's a good day for you was he good
too but next week we're on the upswing
right Anthony yeah yeah do you think the
intern who [ __ ] his pants on the bus
should be being this condescending
towards you no no I don't think anybody
who should
pants on the bus should be condescending
after you do you and on a date with a
stripper porn star and he [ __ ] his pants
and yet somehow he declares himself the
winner oh [ __ ] four drawers is [ __ ] yeah
he'll say he says I get something I got
my integrity I'm a [ __ ] my pants right I
may have never gone on a date with a
stripper pornstar but I tell the truth
right and I used public buses as toilets
absolutely I mean where's a [ __ ] leg
because he says [ __ ] like I stuck to his
leg all it's all that's occurring to me
and [ __ ] bus [ __ ] bus is really [ __ ]
[ __ ] low fat [ __ ] bus yeah [ __ ] bus
that's got a lovely ring to it the [ __ ]
C twins they both have [ __ ] realize that
yeah man well congrats
yeah and everything Niko Congrats on
your stock-raising yeah adulthood well
uh maybe not quite a dolt oh no no
that's the opposite of lived with his
mom and shits on the bus yeah not signs
of being a man oh you're not okay maybe
he told us before that he is never he's
never had a girlfriend girlfriend
doesn't mean I haven't had sex right he
said he's new he has not had a
girlfriend yet but he did have sex with
one girl right one Yeah right
did it go in he said it actually lasted
longer than you would think
so 15 minutes 15 min 12 minutes 12
minutes 12 minutes is more than I do
yes I only happened once yeah so far but
nobody asked you a question will you
propped up on your arms or were you like
facing her neck pumping away it's good
questions yeah what positions huh you're
propped up when you're looking at her
she played your nips know what to say to
her you talk dirty
hey I like to [ __ ] on that exactly you
know they call me [ __ ] bus what'd you
say come on come on it just happened so
fast
twelve minutes of pumping yeah she
wrapping her legs around you where they
just open there'll just why don't you
can say [ __ ] pretty much which is why
your load on our face Wow oh this is a
good boy
you hit rock but you hit it wrong so
what you pulled out you ripped the bag
off and you [ __ ] and you and you
crawled up on your knees and shot her in
the face and that's time that's what she
wanted you to give it to me you pull the
bottom off and busted in her face yeah
that's what she told me mom and dad you
believe him I don't believe I don't know
I think if he told the truth oh [ __ ] my
pants
yeah yeah why would you lie about that
wait why did you pull out get a condom
on just leave it in and it's your first
time don't muck if you have a condom on
you leave it in me point